it's very hard isn't it to detect a lone  individual sitting in a darkened room  with a laptop who has a predisposition  perhaps to some violence  perhaps some low-level criminality and  over quite a short period of time  emerges into radicalized mindset and  then rents a van and carries out all  plans to carry out an atrocity of course  that is very hard to detect and whereas  a decade ago we tended to see physical  radicalization face to face we know now  although the proliferation of extreme  propaganda on the Internet and through  social media means that that sort of  material is generally available to  individuals who may be predisposed to  think in certain ways